Noch warten oder können wir losgehen?
Können wir anfangen.
Okay, dann können wir schon losgehen.
Okay, dann.
Okay, guten Tag.
Schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Arke Mezoglu, ich bin hier der Studentin der Arzt.
Bevor wir anfangen, muss ich Ihre persönliche Daten notieren
und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Bescheiden.
Ist das okay für Sie?
Ja, gerne.
Okay, und zuerst, wie heißen Sie?
Schmidt-Paul.
Herr Paul, können Sie bitte Ihren Vorname nachnehmen, Bustaville?
Vorname ist Paul.
Und nachname ist Schmidt, Paul mit Pewee Paris.
So ist das Bustaville oder das ist einfach.
Da Paul, können Sie einfach schreien.
Schmidt ist auch klar, am Ende mit DT.
Mit DT, okay.
Genau.
Ist auch klar.
Also, das verdienen wir seit.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Schmidt, wie heißen Sie?
Ungefähr jetzt 65 Jahre alt.
75, okay.
Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Haben Sie 75 verstanden oder 65 verstanden?
75 verstanden, habe ich.
Ich habe 65 gesagt, aber es ist nicht stimmt.
Können wir auch 75 machen?
Okay.
Das ist nicht stimmt.
Okay, Entschuldigung.
Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
4.3.1965.
Wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie?
Ungefähr jetzt 70 kg.
Und bin ich 80 groß.
80, okay.
Was sind Sie von der Zeit?
Taxfahrer.
Aber ich fahre nicht mehr.
Ich bin Rentner.
Und ich bin im Ruhestand, sozusagen jetzt.
Bin zu Hause aktuell.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich war verheiratet.
Nicht mehr.
Jetzt sind Sie...
Ledig.
Genau.
Aber sind Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei.
Okay, Herr Schmidt.
Was für Sie schon?
Ich weiß nicht genau, von wo soll ich anfangen.
Aber ich habe so eine starke Bauchschmerzen,
leichte Übelkeit, Appatitlosigkeit.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob ich das einzeln einzeln sehe,
oder würden Sie einfach ein einzeln,
für jede Beschwerden, Frage stellen?
Oder soll ich denn...
Das wäre besser, wenn Sie sehen können.
Aber ich kann auch gerne fragen.
Gerne.
Und als Sie gesagt, Bauchschmerzen, Appatitlosigkeit,
oder dem habe ich keine Kraft, muss ehrlich sein.
Manchmal habe ich auch so eine Fieber.
Ob ich Fieber habe, weiß ich nicht genau,
ich messe es nicht, aber ich fühle mich so warm.
Ansonsten, ja, die sind halt die Probleme,
die ich jetzt habe.
Okay.
Wo sind die Schmerzen genau?
Das ist ein Wechselhaft, ja.
Manchmal sind sie zwischen beiden Schultern,
manchmal ein ganzer Bauch, manchmal ein richtiger Seitbauch,
oder das ist ein einfach Wechselhaft.
Ja, Oberbauch, aber...
Okay.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eines Falles,
von 1 bis 10, und wobei 1 zellert,
10, 6 Tage Schmerzen nicht büchtig?
Ja, wenn ich so einen Schmerzattacke habe,
die liegen zwischen 7 bis 9, würde ich sagen.
Aber so ein Dauerhaft habe ich auch Schmerzen, ja,
ab und zu, so als ich gesagt habe,
dann ist es broide, manchmal rechts, links,
und dann oben, also so ein Dauerhaft Schmerzen
zwischen 1 bis 3, würde ich sagen.
Ich bin nie schmerzfrei in der letzten Zeit.
Was meinen Sie in der letzten Zeit?
Ich meine, seit wann genau haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, aber die Beschwerden sind nicht alles zusammengekommen,
die hat als erst mal angefangen mit so einer leichten Appetitlosigkeit,
das war schon vor ein paar Monaten,
und dann hinterher,
halbzehn, leichte Oberbauchschmerzen gehabt,
dann war wieder weg, dann kam wieder,
und da habe ich auch Stress gehabt in der letzten Zeit,
und manchmal lachte es ein bisschen, war auch so eine Stark,
habe ich gesagt, dass das vielleicht durch den Stress,
dass ich wieder Mahnsäure produziere,
und daher habe ich dann den Mahnschleimhautentzündung,
dann habe ich versucht, mal mit Mahnschutz-Tableten zu abzudicken.
Das ging so ein weiter, aber dann fang es wieder an,
und ja, bis zum Zeitpunkt, das ich gesagt habe,
jetzt muss ich mal zu einer Fachmann gehen,
wo ich genau wissen finden kann, woher Grund ist,
dass ich das genau wissen.
Also ich habe so verstanden, in der letzten Zeit sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden?
Ja genau, ja genau, jetzt ist es nicht mehr so,
manchmal ist es nicht mehr so halten, trotz Schmerzmittel, trotz Mahnschutz-Tableten,
geht es nicht mehr.
Okay.
Haben Sie sich auch erbrochen?
Einmal vielleicht in den letzten zwei Monaten.
Okay.
Haben Sie die Erröhung oder irgendwelche Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Was meinst du mit der Erröhung?
Entschuldigung, der Durchfall.
Ah ja, ja, nein, der Durchfall würde ich nicht sagen,
aber so ein wechselndes Stuhlgang, manchmal so ein leicht wässeriges Durchfall,
ist das nicht, dann ist das bestimmt wässerisch.
Manchmal ist es ganz geformt, manchmal ist es ein bisschen hart, unterschiedlich,
je nach, was ich gegessen habe oder ob ich dann genug Flüssigkeit so ziemlich genommen habe.
Das kann ich nicht genau sagen, aber das ist nicht normal,
muss ich auch erinnern sein.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden oder das wars?
Was soll ich noch haben mit den Probleme?
Ich kann mich nicht konzentrieren.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben, kann ich das beantworten.
Okay.
Ob Sie auch Brust schmeißen?
Zum Beispiel ein enges Gefühl oben ja schon.
Ob das schmeißen ist, das kann ich nicht genau sagen,
aber ein enges Gefühl schon bei Belastung ja.
Und stahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Hab ich gesagt, das ist ein wechselhaften,
das ist ja Oberbauch, manchmal habe ich zwischen beiden Schulterblätter
stark geschmessen, manchmal ist es in der rechten Oberbauchbereich,
natürlich die Strahlung.
Okay.
Und hat sich Ihr Gemüse in der letzten Zeit auch verändert?
Ich meine, habe Sie abgenommen oder zurgenommen?
Ja, gute Frage.
Ich habe keine Ware zu Hause, aber meine Hose sind schon groß,
jetzt muss ich sagen.
Etwas große, ja.
Und ich gehe davon aus, ich habe sie schon abgenommen.
Jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen nach Ihrer Krankengeschichte stellen.
Leider Sie, ich habe mich nicht verstanden,
habe ich noch keine Krankengeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie, an irgendwelche Krankungen,
zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankungen oder eine Tochterung?
Nein, eigentlich, ich war kein gesund bisher.
Ich habe nie etwas gehabt und auch nie Medikamente
sie mich eingenommen.
Aber, ja, ich glaube, ich war gesund, muss ich sagen.
muss ich sagen, ja, dass wir nur für größere Zeit, dass wir ein paar Monate hatten.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt,
Margenstein hat Entschuldigung.
Nee, genau. Ich habe es vermutet, ich weiß es nicht genau, ich habe es nur vermutet, weil...
Asif?
Ja, ja, ich habe wieder eine Arztbesucht, noch eine Untersuchung gehabt
und ich habe es nur vermutet, durch den Erfahrung von den Freunden und Umgebungen,
der Bekannte, dass es könnte sein.
Daraufhin habe ich den Demandenschutz da drin genommen.
Das hat auch ehrlicherweise auch teilweise geholfen.
Bis zu meinem Zeitpunkt.
Das geht es auch nicht mehr.
Haben Sie das selbst eingenommen oder hat das das Haus als Fächer?
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, bin ich ein bisschen faul.
Ich war nie beim Haushalten, auch bis zu diesem Problem.
Ich habe immer fast zurückgelegt und meine Freunde haben immer Tabletten zu Hause extra gehabt.
Dann habe ich von dem genommen einfach.
Okay.
Manchmal 20 bin ich manchmal 40, war so unterschiedlich.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, so ein Blinddarm, ob wir vor 30 Jahren...
Vor 30 Jahren, okay.
Gibt es irgendwelche wesentliche Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Was meinen Sie, so eine gleiche Probleme, die das hatten oder so eine chronische Erkrankung?
Chronische Erkrankungen, meine ich.
Okay.
Soweit ich im Kopf habe, ich kann mich auch nicht konzentrieren, ehrlich zu sein.
Ob die, was hatten, könnte es schon sein, dass ich soweit ich es mal gehört habe, meine Unkann hatte mal, hatte er, also eine Darmkrebs gehabt.
Aber das ist nicht durch die Darmkrebs geschoben und Rampdarmkrebs,
am Ende hatte er einen Halsinfarkt gehabt und ist verstorben.
Meine Vater war kein gesund bis zum Ende, am Ende der Hand hatte er so einen Demenz gehabt und dann verstorben auch.
Und meine Mutter weiß nicht genau, was die hatte, aber die hatte auch nie etwas zu sich eingenommen,
so ein Medikament, meine ich, das scheint, die war auch gesund gewesen war.
Der Unkel, der meine Krebs hatte, mutterliche Seite oder vaterliche Seite?
Irgendwas, ich weiß nicht.
Hatte, die Bruder von meinem Vater.
Okay.
Aber er hatte auch Halsinfarkt?
Ja, als ich sagte, der hatte so einen Darmkrebs gehabt und ist geheilt, der ist operiert worden, damals so ein bestrahlt worden, soweit ich es im Kopf habe.
Und dann, am Ende, dann hat es so ein Halsproblem und dann ist er dadurch verstorben.
Sie meinen, das war ein Halsinfarkt, laut der Erste.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, Sie können sich nicht ermessen, aber haben Sie Ihre Temperatur nicht ermessen, oder?
Nee, ich habe keine Glätshause leider.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Einladen durchschlafen?
Ja, durch den Schmelz, problematisch habe ich schon durch Schlafsturm, ja.
Manchmal stehe ich auf und muss sich etwas einnehmen, so ein Schmelzmittel und es dauert ein, zwei Stunden, bis es es wird und dann kann ich den durchschlafen.
Wenn ich wieder schlafe, schenke ich einfach, ja, krebsanhaft.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nee, habe ich gar kein Problem.
Herr Schmidt, haben Sie, Sie haben ja gesagt, Sie haben Stress, mit wem oder mit was haben Sie Stress eigentlich?
Mit Leben.
Können Sie das beseitigen?
Ja, ich kann jedes Stress sehen, aber ich kann sagen, ich glaube, jeder hat im Leben noch Stress und es ist auch manchal benötigt, aber es ist halt so, ja, jeder hat seine Probleme im Leben und familiäre und umgebung und finanziell kann ich nicht alles genau beschreiben, aber es ist halt so.
Muss man halt durchschalten.
Ja, Sie sollen positiv sein, vor allem für Ihre Gesundheit, ja.
Ja, genau, haben Sie Fallrecht. Ich bemühe mich.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen das Schmelzmittel und Magenschutz ein, wiesen Sie genau die Namen von dem Anlekarment?
Ja, ich habe so einen Weg verlaufen, mal Ibogrofin, mal Novalgin, Neuvalmin, so einen Freund sagen die das und Magenschutz-Tabletten, weil immer Pante Prasol.
Und Ibogrofin und Neuvalgin, wie viele?
Okay, ich meine.
Entschuldigung, Ibogrofin 400, ist das alles?
Ja, ja, ja, Ibogrofin.
Ja, Ibogrofin 400, ab und zu auch so eine Neuvalgin-Tabletten, so ein 500 bis 1000 Milligramm.
Was Sie nehmen, sonst keine Medikamente?
Nee, mehr hatte ich nie gebraucht auch, ich habe versucht, dass ich mit diesem Medikament einfach die Probleme so weit wie möglich zu kontrollieren, aber als Sie gesagt, das ging bis zu einer Weile und danach nicht mehr.
Und wie trafen Sie?
Ich habe nicht mehr geraucht, aber bis vor 20 Jahren, ungefähr 30 Jahre habe ich geraucht.
Wie viele haben Sie genau?
Ungefähr 20 bis pro Tag.
Wie viel haben Sie Alkohol?
Ab und zu.
Was dir denn tun Sie?
Zumal Bier und zumal mit Freunden einfach so ein Kreuz, ein Schnaps am Wochenende eher.
Nee, habe ich nie genommen, habe ich auch nie probiert.
Okay, sind Sie mal hin, irgendwelche Allergien oder Unfertigungsigkeiten gekannt?
Nee, ist auch nicht bekannt.
Ich habe vergessen eine Frage über die Schmerzen zu stellen.
Können Sie bitte, wie die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Ich meine, wie sind die Schmerzen eher dunf oder stichend?
Als Sie gesagt haben, wenn ich die Attacke habe, dann müsste ich am meisten die Messer stichend schmerzen.
Als jemand einfach Messer reinstiegt.
Manchmal sind es natürlich so dunf Schmerzen.
Das ist erst, wenn ich meine Medikamente genommen habe, spätestens nicht so stichend schmerzen,
sondern so dunf Schmerzen, sondern so Druckschmerzen.
Nach einer Weile lasse ich nach, aber nicht ganz, aber ich habe immer so dauerhaft Schmerzen.
Das muss man eigentlich sein, als etwas nicht in Ordnung ist für mein Magen oder Bauchbereich,
ich weiß nicht genau, wo das genau ist, aber deswegen bin ich hergekommen, um abzuqueren lassen.
Okay. Und haben Sie auch Schluckstörung oder Husteln?
Schluckstörung habe ich nicht.
Und Husteln?
Husteln habe ich auch nicht.
Okay, Herr Schmerzen. Jetzt bin ich mit der Frage fertig. Möchten Sie etwas umzufügen oder fragen?
Nein, eigentlich will man gerne wissen, was ich habe und was ich noch machen soll
oder was Sie noch machen müssen.
Eigentlich ist es zufüllen, etwas Konfnete zu sagen.
Ich werde Sie zuerst pöpeltisch untersuchen und dann nehme ich Ihnen Blut auf, um Labor durchzuführen.
Und ich verlinke das für Sie einen Ultraschall und Ihrem Bauch.
Ja, und jener Ergäte können wir auch bei Ihnen einen City durchführen.
Können wir genauer sprechen.
Okay, das heißt, ich bleibe erst mal ins Krankenhaus, damit ich den die ganze Untersuchung bekommen soll.
Ja, oder dürfen.
Ja, jetzt können Sie mir das mal klarstimmen und dann bin ich mit der Frage.
Alles klar, danke schön. Haben wir etwas vergessen?
Im Runde müssen wir eine Frage stellen.
Ich habe eine Frage, ob ich im Ausland gewesen war.
Ja, das auch.
Ja, aber ich war nicht im Ausland. Einfach Antwort.
Okay.
Was noch haben wir vergessen?
Ist das etwas, was die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Genau, gute Frage.
Erlassung abhängig oder Ernährungsabhängig?
Genau.
Oder noch andere?
Abhängig, habe ich es schon gesagt.
Was?
Hab ich gesagt, nach dem Essen habe ich...
Manchmal, ja, manchmal.
Aber genauer habe ich nicht beschrieben oder haben Sie auch nicht gefragt.
Aber grundsätzlich ist unterschiedlich.
Manchmal kann ich nicht genau beschreiben.
Manchmal nach dem Essen, manchmal vor dem Essen.
Das kann ich nicht genau beschreiben.
Aber Sie haben vor Recht, teilweise habe ich auch beschrieben.
Okay.
Was noch?
Vielleicht nach Schweiß.
Nach Schweiß, ja, das haben Sie, ich glaube, Sie haben gefragt,
ob, nein, nach Schweiß haben Sie nicht gefragt.
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Nach Schweiß war noch, genau, das ist auch noch so Fragen.
Ja, ich schwitze manchmal ab und zu auch in der Nacht.
Muss ich meine Unterwäsche manchmal auch manchmal wechseln.
Aber das ist aber in der letzten Woche.
Am Anfang hatte ich das nicht gehabt.
Das ist neu.
Haben Sie im Stuhl gemerkt?
Blut im Stuhl, gute Frage.
Ich habe es nicht gemerkt.
Aber in der letzten Zeit ist es ein bisschen schwarzer Stuhl.
Ich habe das auch so ein paar Tage gehabt.
Und dann ging das wieder weg.
Und da war wieder normal.
Ja, ich höre noch.
Gibt es noch Fragen?
Nein, dann.
Die Medikamente dosieren insgesamt wie oft.
Und wie viel.
Ich habe es schon vertiefen.
Ich habe nun gesagt, dass schon 400 Medikamente pro Pfinn einnehmen
oder so manchmal eine Valgy.
Das kann man auch ein bisschen vertiefen.
Und der Alkoholmenge habe ich schon übersichtlich auch dann gesagt,
dass ich dann mal Wein und mal Bier trinken.
Das kann man auch ein bisschen vertiefen.
Nur als Tipps zu sagen.
Und kann sein in der Prüfung, dass es eins genommen wird.
Weil die Menge auf die Brüche ist auch wichtig.
Und das weiß ich noch.
Zu erklären oder fragen.
Ich glaube, der Rest haben wir gut alles beschrieben.
Sie haben es auch gut zu sagen.
Und haben wir das auch gefragt.
Im Sinne von, dass es was relevant sein soll.
Okay, dann fangen wir mit dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Okay.
Fangen wir an?
Ja, okay.
Hallo, Herr Oberarzt.
Ja, schon guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen an neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Aber sie sind kurz dafür.
Ja, gerne.
Der Patient heißt Parth.
Er ist 35 Jahre alt.
Und hat zwei Kinder.
Er ist Rentner, jetzt in Röhrstand.
Er kam heute zu uns wegen Stärke.
Er hat eine Abdominal-Schmerzen.
Er ist in Appetit, Fatig und leichter.
Der Patient hat Liebe Schweden.
Liebe Schweden, er hat vor ein paar Monaten angefangen.
Aber mit der Zeit ist er schlimmer geworden.
Der Patient hat gesagt, der Ort von Schmerzen ist abwechslend.
Aber er in Epigastrium,
der Patient, der Patient,
kann man das so beschreiben,
dass der Patient schmerzen kann nicht genau lokalisieren.
Aber es ist er Oberbauchschmerzen.
Ja.
Das ist vielleicht besser, wenn man so beschreibt.
Es ist nur einfach Tipps,
das ist auch anders beschreiben.
Der Patient kann die Schmerzen nicht genau lokalisieren.
Aber er Oberbauchschmerzen.
Er hat gesagt,
der Patient, der Patient,
der Patient, der Schmerzen,
bei der Schmerzintage steht,
bei Attacken mit 7 bis 9.
Auf der Schmerzvalofonone 1 bis 10,
bei Leichterschmerzen mit 1 bis 3.
Er hat in der letzten Zeit Stress.
Deswegen habe der Patient gedacht, dass er Gastriptis haben könnte.
Und er hat Panthoprazol manchmal 20, manchmal 40, mir genommen.
Das hat ihm nicht ganz geholfen.
Insbesondere bei Belastung hat der Patient manchmal eng gegeben.
Aber die Frage nach Bruschermelzen wurde vernehmt.
Er hat gesagt, dass seine Kleidung größer geworden.
Und deswegen hat er vermutet, dass er Abbenutzerts.
Und er hat auch gesagt, er fühlt sich fibrisch.
Aber die Temperatur hat er nicht gemessen.
Bei den Patienten ist keine wesentliche Vorerkrankungen bekannt.
Als Operationen hatte er eine Apennikromie vor 30 Jahren gehabt.
Familienanalyse ergab.
Und Onkel, vaterlicherseits, hatte Kolonkartsnummer.
Das wurde behandelt.
Dann hat er Mio-Cardinfarkt und Anmio-Cardinfarkt verstorben.
Und vater ist andermens verstorben.
Die vegetative Analyse ist unaufwählig, bis auf Fibagefühl, Parasomie und Inapetenz.
Er hat Stress mit dem Neben.
Als Medikamente nimmt er 400 mg Neubilgen, manchmal 500, manchmal 1000 mg.
Und man tut pro Zoll 20-40 mg ein.
Er gibt einen M-Algen-Kotinabus von 30 Jahren lang, 20 Zucarretten pro Tag.
Das war vor 20 Jahren.
Und er gibt einen gelegentlichen Alkoholkonsum an.
Die Fragen wurden Drogenkonsum, wurde Fennalz.
Bei den Patienten ist keinerlei, die getan.
Sie sagen immer, dass es passiert, dass sie berichtet sind.
Sie können auch sagen, dass es passiert, dass sie berichtet sind.
Aber grundsätzlich ist es auch okay, wenn sie es auch so sagen.
Haben wir etwas vergessen?
Wir haben alles richtig berichtet.
Der Patient hat grundsätzlich eine Bauchschmessung, er ist Oberbauch.
Die Beschwerden sind seit Monaten lang, aber genau wie lange.
Wissen Sie auch nicht genau?
Haben Sie auch nicht gefragt, wie viele Monate?
2, 3, 4, 5, 7, wissen wir auch nicht genau.
Das haben wir nicht gefragt.
Aber seid man genau der Patient von 2 Monaten?
Genau, aber können Sie immer helfen.
Ja, können Sie sich reden, vielleicht ist es 2 Monate, 3 Monate, 4 Monate.
Das ist immer besser.
Weil als Patient, wenn man in den Notaufnahmen kommt,
dann berichtet man nicht alles genau.
Man versucht den Akquellestand oder Akquellestprobleme zu beschreiben.
Der Rest, was hinter sich da ist, ist auch nicht wichtig für ihn oder für er.
Aber das kann sich vertiefen.
Die hat einen Bonus langen Bauchschmessung,
die hat Gewichtabnahme, anamnistisch, so weit wie wissen.
Genau wie viele Kilo.
Das können wir auch nicht herausfinden.
B-Symptomatik, teilweise ja, schon passt das.
Und was würden Sie jetzt machen?
Sie haben so eine Fall in den Notaufnahmen und mit Überbauchschmessung.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt?
Diagnostik.
Diagnostik würde ich zuerst die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Genau.
Was achten Sie mit dem körperlich untersuchen?
Natürlich ist die wichtigste Teil am domino der Untersuchung.
Was würden Sie mit der terminalen Untersuchung genau wissen?
Was ist denn Ihre Stil?
Schmerzlokalisation.
Genau.
Was noch?
Organomegalin.
Ja, Organomegalin.
Natürlich ist der Podermagalin.
Genau.
Abdominal können Sie auch Darmgeräusche hören.
Auch noch das auskultatorisch, wie Sie nicht so weit.
Aber diese 3-4 Punkte sind richtig.
Die haben Sie gemacht.
Der Patient hat Überbauchschmessung, hat einen Druck.
Der Sensible-Druckschmessung, der Überbauchbereich.
Der hat wieder Hepatomegalin, Spinomegalin.
Was machen Sie weiter mit dem körperlichen?
Die Kolleginnen sind fleißig, schreiben in Tat schon,
was man schauen soll.
Sie achten auf die Lymphknoten auch noch das zu.
Wenn jemand so mit einer bisentomatischen Weine kommt,
dann sollen Sie auch bei Verdacht oder Vermutung
auf einer Krebsart oder einer so zu sagen Tumorerkrankung
dann sollen Sie doch die Lymphknoten auch tassen.
Auch wenn das normal ist, dann gehört noch das zu.
Sie machen eine Halstimfknotenuntersuchung.
Sie machen eine superaxellere,
Sie machen auch die axellere Lymphknotenuntersuchung.
Das heißt, die Lymphknoten sind auch bei Körperuntersuchung achten.
Egal auch, wenn das an der Nischung auch nicht passt.
Bei Körperuntersuchung müssen Sie machen.
Das gehört dazu.
Das kann auch eine Entzündung sein, weiß man nicht.
Durch die Entzündung hat eine Dimpftnotenvergrößerung.
Aber das sollen Sie erfassen.
Okay, das haben Sie gemacht.
Dann machen Sie noch weiter Körperuntersuchung.
Der hat gesagt, dass der in der letzten Tag bis vor ein paar Tage
hat so eine schwarze Stuhlgang gehabt.
Ja, deswegen Rektal-Lungtage.
Rektal-digital machen Sie unbedingt.
Sie gehen auch mit dem Finger rein,
gucken Sie, ob der eine Stuhlgang normal ist.
Oder mindestens sehen Sie Blutemüll im Finger
oder ist es eine schwarze Stuhl.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Das heißt, bei Körperuntersuchung haben wir
schon teilweise alles gemacht.
Alles nicht, aber schon.
Dann machen Sie aus kultatorisch mungen Bauch.
Hören Sie ab, auch das heißt,
muss man auch mit Untersuchung zu sagen.
Falls etwas ist, tut mir leid,
dass meine Kleine einfach sehr empfängig ist.
Dann geht nichts mit Mama.
Aber ich muss leider auch mitmachen.
Und so ist er weint.
Und, ja, ich weiß nicht.
Und was wir noch machen sollen,
ja, dann erstellen Sie weiter.
Sie haben jetzt Körperuntersuchung nöschgeführt.
Was machen Sie das Nächstes?
Okay, und dann Blutabnahme.
Blutabnahme, genau.
Blutpink, großes Blutpink und schon noch Parameter.
Okay.
Okay, und Beifahrt auf.
Magenkartner und eigentlich,
sozusagen, Magenkartner, ich glaube,
tomorrow marken es auch.
Aber vielleicht, dass...
Jetzt vermuten Sie, dass deine Magenkartner noch ist?
Ja.
Konzentrieren Sie sich nur auf diese Punkte?
Oder denken Sie auch, das könnte schon etwas anders sein?
Dann kann ich auch noch ein paar andere Untersuchen
durchführen müssen.
Natürlich, das könnte auch etwas anders sein.
Aber ich habe nicht gesagt,
dass mein Verdacht Diagnose her ist,
Magenkartner.
Genau, ich gehe davon aus, dass es auch so ist.
Aber das könnte auch etwas anders sein.
Ja.
So ein Anamnesis könnte auch etwas anders sein, ja.
Nicht.
Wir verstehen, hat es ja auch Alkohol-Anamnese.
Wir verstehen auch Nicotin-Ablösung an Amnese.
Dann, wenn das so das Fall ist,
dann könnte auch schon eine andere Organprobleme,
die nebenbei das machen,
die auch sein, die dann auf dem Magen,
indirekt auch Probleme verursacht.
Ja.
Wenn Sie Blutabnehmen, wenn Sie einen Körperuntersuchung machen,
das könnte auch Gallengangprobleme sein,
das könnte dann Gallenblaseprobleme sein,
das könnte dann der Leberprobleme sein.
Ja.
Oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Was denkt denn Sie als Differentialdiagnose
in diesem Fall?
Differentialdiagnostisch kommen.
Bevor wir die weitere Lavauxuntersuchung,
auch den Diagnostikuntersuchung machen,
dann müssen Sie wissen, was Sie als erstes denken
und was soll Sie als Differentialdiagnose
hier auch in Betracht nehmen.
Ja.
Differentialdiagnostisch kommen zum Beispiel
Osofaguskarchnom.
Okay.
Schulstistitis, Cholitis oder Cholistitis?
Schulstistitis kann so einen Verlauf haben.
Unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, weil die kürzische Schulstistitis
sind immer so ein gutes Ereignis.
Sie haben es, das kommt als Attacan,
geht wieder weg und dann haben Sie wieder
so ein paar Späte, paar Wochen nochmal.
Wenn das bei Letiasis,
Schulstistitis bei Letiasis,
am meisten ist durch den Nahrungs.
Wenn Sie ein kürzer Reiches essen,
dann haben Sie am meisten Probleme.
Dann passt auch nicht genau.
Da müssen Sie auch dann entsprechend
auch anamnesisieren.
Wenn Sie dann anamnesisch durchführen,
ob das auch sowas sein können.
Und wir haben das gefragt.
Das passt nicht.
Das Prangial hat ja manchmal gar keine Schmelzen.
Aber dann passt nicht.
Was könnte noch sein?
Was kann noch sein?
Und Christian?
Ja, das könnte passen.
Es ist nicht ganz typisch, aber könnte passen.
Es ist nicht typisch, aber ja.
Aber es ist trotzdem mit der Magen,
was du tun hast.
Was noch?
Hab ich gesagt?
Ja, das ist unwahrscheinlich.
Aber von Richtung Lymphom
sollte es eine verschiedene Sache sein.
Natürlich geht es auch an Art von Lymphom.
Die Magensitze zu sagen.
Das ist auch, haben Sie Frau Richter,
aber sehr selten zu sehen.
Kann man auch eine Hepatitis hier in Betracht nehmen.
Eine Hepatitis-Infektion,
die in der letzten Zeit
seine Lebesteroose verursacht habe,
muss man nicht eine Hepatitis haben.
Das Hepatitis kann man auch haben.
Aber dadurch, dass man auch
eine Erhörter-Garlandsauer,
die eine Reflex auf den Magen macht
und natürlich durch den,
dann hat das chronische Schmelz in den Ur- und Ur-Aufbereich
Erregter oder Mitter, das kann man nicht genau lokalisieren.
Das könnte auch sein.
Das muss nicht, aber muss man auch dran denken.
Also die Pferenzialdiagnose.
Wenn man sowas hat,
dann kann man auch so einen Varis haben.
An der Nessung hat auch gesagt,
dass er so einen Blut im Stuhl gehabt hat.
Manchmal hat man Varisblutung
und dann geht das unten.
Ich versuche Ihnen einfach,
die gesamter Paket,
das sein könnte,
dort in diesem Bereich zu erwähnen.
Aber als nicht,
dass die alle genauer passen mit der Anamnese.
Sie haben es richtig gedacht,
dass das auch wahrscheinlich eine Magenkasse ist.
Aber Sie sind noch nicht sicher auch.
Dafür brauchen Sie noch weit Untersuchungen.
Die werden auch so eine umfangreiches Frage stellen.
Könnte das sein, könnte das sein?
Man fragt, warum nicht das, warum nicht das.
Und davor müssen Sie auch dieser Background haben.
Muss ich das die Hintergrund haben?
Warum nicht das, warum nicht das?
Da sollen Sie auch wissen.
Sie haben gesagt, das Magenkasse in den Umfeldach.
Nehmen Sie Blut ab jetzt.
Was nehmen Sie denn?
Ja, großes Blutbild,
Entzündungsparameter,
Leber-Enzyme,
AST, ALT
und
ich achte auch
Wiederbeinwerte.
Gamme, GP, AP.
Ja,
also für
Pakets.
Wenn Sie in Deutschland so,
wenn Sie eine große Frage haben,
wenn Sie in Deutschland so,
wenn Sie eine große Blutbild machen
oder eine große Routine, sagt man am meisten,
dann haben Sie eine große Routine,
eine große Blutbild,
Sie haben dann Leberwerte,
Sie haben dann Punk,
Sie haben dann Nierenwerte,
Sie haben dann Elektrolyte drin,
Sie haben dann LDH auch drin,
Sie haben dann auch den CIP auch drin.
Sie versuchen immer zu sagen,
natürlich ist es wechselhaft,
in jedem Krankenhaus große Routine,
weil Kardiologen sind Kardialen,
in Zümer auch noch dazu.
In jeder Teilung,
in diesem Bereich kann sich ändern,
sind Leberwerte,
sind Kardialen in Zümer,
aber grundsätzlich ist es vieles drin.
Die Kollegin hat geschrieben,
C-Kit-Mutation.
Was ist das?
Können Sie das beschreiben,
was das ist, genau.
Ich weiß nicht,
ich weiß nicht,
aber so tief untersuchen,
brauchen Sie nicht in der Mutopnau.
Marenkast und Tumomarker,
bei Maren gibt es keine Tumomarker,
was man im Buch liest,
da gibt es keine Marenkast,
Sie können es ja als Jahr 1999 machen,
aber die sind auch nicht typisch,
die sind auch nicht typisch,
macht man nicht
wieder vor dem Diagnostik
oder nach dem
beim Nachsorgen,
macht man keine Tumomarker untersuchen.
Aber kann man alles abnehmen,
die Zeit Tumomarker
ist ja als Jahr 19,
der Stand, das man macht,
der Respirante nicht unbedingt.
Sie haben jetzt gut beschrieben,
die haben Körperuntersuchung durchgeführt,
sie haben Blutbild gemacht,
große Routine,
das ist noch als nächstes zu machen.
Sie haben auch gemacht,
warum machen Sie eine Unterscheinung?
Ja,
durch den Unterschein
können wir
Leber untersuchen.
Was erwarten Sie,
was wollen Sie sehen im Leber?
Wir sollen passieren.
Wir wollen,
dass die Leber
nicht mehr so gut ist,
nicht mehr so gut ist.
Was soll passieren?
Paranchöre Konsistenz
oder
wir untersuchen auch Gallenblasen.
Was Sie sehen?
Partite
können wir etwas sehen.
Partite,
sehen Sie beim
Metallunterschein?
Nein,
sehen Sie nicht.
Sie haben es gut beschrieben,
Sie wollen sehen,
ob die Kontur
gleichmäßig
oder unregelmäßig ist.
Die Rand
ist für Sie
regelmäßig,
ob sie großartig ist
oder ob sie ein Herd sehen.
Sie haben es gut beschrieben,
Sie wollen sehen,
ob die Leber normal sind
oder nicht,
ob sie eine Metastase haben
durch den Demarkas in den Ohren.
Das können Sie auch sehen und untersuchen.
So genau
die Gallenblase können Sie genau darstellen.
Sie wollen mal
sehen, ob da eine Stein drin ist
oder nicht, aber wenn es hündet ist,
ob der Wand verdick ist,
die Gallenblasewand.
Die sind einfach die Frage,
warum man ein Auto schon böscht
bei oberkastlenschnalen
Probleme.
Magenausgang sehen Sie auch,
wenn es eine Verdickung ist,
das sehen Sie auch in den Unterscheiden.
Je nach Erfahrung,
wenn man gut Erfahrung hat,
sieht man das, wenn nicht,
dann sieht man das.
Was noch zu sehen mit dem Unterscheiden?
Freie Flüssigkeiten
in diesem Fall.
Können wir sehen,
wenn es gibt.
Ja, dann geht es ja in den Bauchbereich,
aber im Oberbauchbereich,
das würden Sie noch sehen.
Wenn Sie
ein Oberbauchprobleme haben,
müssen Sie unbedingt eine
Panker-Darstellung haben
oder haben sollen.
Ich habe ja zuletzt ein Patient gehabt,
die
eine junge Frau von 40 Jahren alt
kam mit dem Oberbauchschmelzen,
Stalkoberbauchschmelzen,
der Klinik war so,
wie ein Magenkastel.
Dann haben wir gesagt,
okay, wir machen einen Otterschall,
Panker ist ein Posit,
der Pankerskopf war ein bisschen
ein bisschen fangroßer,
aber nicht ganz so
eine typische, so zu sagen.
Dann sind wir ein bisschen
in der Magnespiedlung,
dort sieht man, dass in Pars 2,
d.h. in den Dödenum Pars 2
reicht, dass der Pankerskopf
einfach von außen druckt
auf den Dödenum
dort.
Man sieht dann richtig,
die kann man auch so ein Otterschall
sogar sehen manchmal,
aber das braucht man normalerweise
noch dazu.
Aber mit dem gleichen Symptomatik,
aber war keine Magenkastel,
eine Pankerskastel.
Daher müssen sie auch den Pankers darstellen,
mit dem Otterschall.
Okay, sehr gut.
Den Kollegen hat auch beschrieben,
die Pankers in Zuma,
bei Panker Titis,
bei chronischer Panker Titis haben sie
auch so eine erhöhte Pankers
in Zuma,
aber bei chronisch normalerweise nicht.
Wenn man richtig chronisch Panker Titis hat,
wir springen jetzt von Thema zu Thema,
dann hat man
keine mehr in Zuma zu produzieren.
Man kommt
nebenbei
mit einer Alkoholik mit Überbauchschmelzen
mit
einer Schub von
Akut auf chronischer Panker Titis,
sie machen so eine Lipase amilase,
aber Lipase sind auch normal,
auch amilase sind auch normal.
Wenn man fragt, sich hat er eine Panker Titis,
dann sagt man, nee, warum?
Da hat keiner amilase Lipase, das stimmt nicht.
Hat keine,
weil die Pankers produziert es nicht mehr.
Da hat chronische Probleme.
Und daher muss man sich
klinisch und nach
bildmorphologisch konzentrieren.
Wenn klinischer Anamnistisch
typisch für Panker Titis ist,
dann sagt man, das ist auch
klinisch, Panker Titis.
Ich kann auch nicht anders denken,
dann macht keine CT,
dann schluss, dann behandle ich das sofort.
Wenn ich das mit dem CT auch bestätigt bekommen habe.
Natürlich, sie brauchen immer
weiterer Untersuchung, weil sie mit einer
Untersuchung zu Labur oder Uterschärfte
nicht alles ausschließen.
Auch mit einer Mahlenschwingung können sie auch nicht ausschließen.
Die sind alle,
sozusagen,
Meta, die
zusammen durchgeführt werden,
dass man den genau derzeit
findet.
Sie haben ja zu Untersuchung gemacht,
Sie haben der Leber gesehen,
Garland, Garland gesehen,
Garland Blaser gesehen, Pankers gesehen,
Mehlsauch gesehen,
da habe ich auch gesucht, Opacitis gibt es.
Was machen Sie noch weiter?
CT, aber
ich finde mir nicht sicher,
ich meine beide Anamnise habe ich CT gesagt.
Man kann auch ein ERCP
machen.
Warum nicht eine Gastroskopie?
Eigentlich, die sind fast ähnlich.
Nein, die sind nicht ähnlich.
Die sind nicht ähnlich.
Ja, okay, bei Gastroskopie
es geht um
Spargel und Oden.
Bei ERCP
geht das ein bisschen weiter.
Bei der ERCP, Sie wollen den
Garlandgang in der Leber darstellen.
ERCP ist in der
Eröffnung von ERCP.
Sie können das beschreiben.
Was meinst du?
Was heißt denn ERCP?
Interal, Retrograde,
Konkretikografie.
Ja, genau.
Das heißt Retrograde,
das sind die Skrups, Sie machen das
mit der Eröffnung.
Das ist das,
das sind die Skrups, Sie machen
schlanger Retrograde.
Das heißt,
das geht um Garlandgang und Pankers
in Gangbarre,
nichts tun mit Marke.
Ja, ja.
Ja?
Zuerst Marke Spiegel.
Genau, da heißt,
Sie machen seine Marke Spiegel.
Bei jedem Passant, die
eine Oberwochschmessung hat,
Sie machen immer eine Marke Spiegel.
Außer, wenn Sie
eine typische Oberwochschmessung
auch an einem Nistisch
bei Verdacht auf Scholangitis haben.
Und dies bestrug
sagen Sie, wenn das Scholangitis ist.
Normalerweise sagt man,
okay, ist es
eine Scholangitis
bei
Scholostysuliteasis
oder es ist durch den Pankretitis,
oder es ist dann
dann rein Scholangitis durch den
Gallenstau in der Leber.
Dann,
dort brauchen Sie auch nicht
ESCP sofort, Sie können es machen.
Sie brauchen eine MRCP
erst mal.
Und wenn mit einem MRCP,
dann sehen Sie die Gallengang genau,
ob Sie eine Stein dort haben
oder nicht in den Ausgangbereich
der Pankers.
Und dann können Sie sagen, ja,
gehe ich jetzt mit dem ESCP rein
und dann nehme ich die Stein raus
und dann geht es durch den Gallenstau.
So können Sie es machen.
Aber auch nach Reihen,
Sie können nicht direkt mit dem ESCP losgehen,
können Sie machen, aber
das ist nicht empfindungswert.
Aber Gastroskopie haben Sie jetzt,
haben Sie gemacht und Sie haben gesehen,
dass die hat ein Antrombereich in der große
Herde,
unser,
unser Ritwisch sozusagen,
so eine Herde
und leicht blutet auch
der Rest
ist klar, Sie nehmen Biopsidot davon,
schicken Sie den Spatulon
und dann müssen die Pathologen entscheiden,
wer gerade von Tumor ist.
Aber wenn Sie das gesehen haben,
was machen Sie noch, weiß ich,
Sie haben gesehen, eine Tumor malen.
Was machen Sie denn?
Ich mach nur
Sie machen
Sie machen eine CT
jetzt in diesem Fall, genau.
Weil Sie haben es gesehen,
dass die Tumor malen, sehr gut.
Ist das alles?
Nein, Sie brauchen natürlich
eine genaues
Untersuchung im Sinne von,
wie tief die Tumor ist.
Ist das nur im Malen drin
oder ist das eine Tumor,
die den Marenwand auch durchgingen?
Das ist T1, T2, T3.
Das wussten Sie nicht wissen,
aber Sie müssen nur wissen,
Sie brauchen eine CT, um zu gucken,
ob die Tumor ist lokal oder gestreut
oder metastasiert.
Darauf brauchen Sie eine Bildgebung.
Der Rest müssen Sie nicht wissen,
ob das ist T3, T4,
aber Sie müssen einfach wissen,
dass Sie eine CT brauchen,
um die Tumor-Stadium
zu
sozusagen erfassen.
Welche Stadion ist das?
1, 2, 3, 4,
Sie können das mit einer CT machen.
Leider mit einem Gasus-Cupik
können Sie das nicht finden.
Okay, dann.
Wir haben das gemacht,
denn das ist okay.
Wir brauchen Sie nicht,
eigentlich.
Weil ich das aus, wir haben alles gemacht, oder?
Haben wir etwas vergessen?
Vielleicht haben wir das,
das Zintigraphie oder PCT,
aber das ist weiter.
PCT
ist sehr berühmt in der Türkei,
aber hier ist nicht.
Man braucht nicht unbedingt
eine PCT.
PCT brauchen Sie nur,
wenn Sie sagen,
dass sich Tumor nicht lokalisieren kann
und ich weiß nicht genau, wo Ihr kommt.
Vor allem bei Indyquin-Tumor,
bei
Coup-Art von Tumor,
wo denn die
Hauptfokus nicht klar ist,
aber
wenn Sie ein klares Tumor fokussieren,
dann brauchen Sie einfach
eine CT.
Und das reicht das aus.
Ne, brauchen Sie nicht.
Herr Kollege, Sie haben das nicht gehört,
Sie haben das kaputt gemacht.
Ja, pardon.
Okay,
als ich gesagt habe, Sie brauchen nur CT.
PCT brauchen Sie nicht unbedingt.
Nur bei unklares Tumor-Art,
dann können Sie das machen.
Vor allem bei Indyquin-Tumor ist es standard
auf Care-PCT zu machen.
Ansonsten
bei
abdominalen Metastasen,
z.B. Matthias auch gut.
Sie können in die CT-Torrex
mit Matthias Abdoumen fahren lassen,
falls Sie sagen, ja, ich
will das noch ein bisschen mehr konkret sehen,
aber,
guck mal, wir machen so Unterricht jetzt hier.
Und
ich kann laufen
auch mit Ihnen reden, darüber.
So auch.
Und daher,
wenn PCT, als Sie gerade kommen, nicht in Frage unbedingt.
Okay, was machen wir noch,
dann, Herr Schleswig?
Im Runder fragen wir auf die Kollege noch eine andere Idee,
ob wir etwas vergessen haben.
Ja,
die hat geschrieben,
aber
nicht sagen.
Das ist sehr, sehr kompliziertes
Sache, die ihr nicht braucht.
Das ist eine fachliche Sache.
Das wird es in den Prüfungen gefragt,
was für Therapie soll man das anbieten?
Hier,
der Therapie richtet sich nach
der Gestaltung von
das Tumor.
Wenn die Gestaltung weiß,
das ist der Opel, wir stellen uns 2, 3, 4.
Und dann ist es schon 2, 3, dann
muss es denn,
Neogurant mit Chemo-Tereipi und dann, je nach
welcher Tumorart es ist, auch Platinepizzerie
oder Adeokastionum,
das sind in sich auch,
Neogurant,
OP,
als ich sagte,
und da gibt es noch sehr vertiefes
Untersuchungen,
im Sinne von Tumorarten
und Receptoren.
Heute Tag, man versucht auch,
vieles
Molekular-Untersuchung
durchzuführen,
im Sinne von zum Beispiel PDL1,
RSV-Status
und noch seltene
Motationen, die man auch nicht
sieht
und da
ein personalisiertes
Behandlung zu anzubieten können.
Als sie gesagt,
daher
die Therapie richtet sich nach
den Tumostademen und Tumorarten.
Das wird
nicht gefragt bei Ihnen in der Prüfung,
das ist, das ist
eine fachliches
Frage, das kann man nur
in der Umkologie
stellen,
nicht bei einer
Approbationsfachs-
Prüfung.
Wenn jemand so eine Frage stellt,
das finde ich ein bisschen schon
ungewöhnlich und
unferm, muss ich sagen.
Haben wir alles jetzt
besprochen
oder gibt es noch etwas,
was wir noch besprechen sollen?
Mussten Patienten
im Krankenhaus bleiben?
gute Frage.
Wenn Sie nicht sicher sind,
dass die Patient
ist mal auch klinisch das wichtig,
laborisch
klinisch, ihre Eindruck
und zusammen, dann können Sie
entscheiden, ob die Patienten
lassen werden, kann man das ambulant
durchführen oder soll man das
gestoßen. Diese drei Sachen sind sehr wichtig.
Wenn Sie sehen, dass die Laborbete
auffällig sind, dass die Patient
starker Blutarmut hat,
dass die starker Hörteinzündung
werden hat oder Elektroloat im
Ballern, oder Nierenentzuffizienz
oder Lebewettererstechterung,
da muss unbedingt der Stationär bleiben.
Da können Sie nicht sagen, dass wir sind gehen kann.
Das ist der erste Sache, die Sie achten sollen.
Zweitens, wenn
klinisch nicht so gut ist, auch wenn
die Laborbete okay sind, aber klinisch geht sie
eben nicht gut, dann sollen sie auch
stationär behalten.
Drittes, dass Sie
das Gefühl haben, dass die Patientambulant das nicht schafft,
Diagnostik
durchzuführen, dann sollen sie
bitte stationär behalten.
Die Kasse
auch bezahlt das.
Außer, wenn die Patientin sagt, ich will
trotzdem gehen, dann sollen sie gegen
erstes michere Rat entlassen lassen.
Nicht, dass sie sagen, okay,
Sie dürfen gehen, so geht das nicht in
Deutschland.
Wenn Sie so ein Patient haben, wenn Sie sagen,
wenn Sie wissen, dass das eine lebensbedrohliche
Situation ist, kann sein, der Patient geht
nach Hause, blutet
auf einmal und stirbt.
Dann fragt man sich,
die war doch im Krankenhaus bei Stunden,
warum es sie entlassen worden,
dann haben sie keine Absicherung.
Davon müssen Sie sich immer gegen
erstes über Rat unterschreiben lassen.
Sie können gerne gehen, aber bitte
unterschreiben Sie hier, dass Sie die
Entscheidung selbst getroffen haben,
dass Sie sich keine Verantwortung übernehmen.
So können Sie es machen.
Sonst sind es am meisten bei
älteren Patienten
Diagnostik, das ist eine
ambulante Macht, man selten
noch fragen.
War das ein schwieriger Fall
oder
ich glaube
ich glaube auch, ja, was denn das.
Wir müssen die
Anamnese aus der Nase sehen.
Ja, die Anamnese.
Ja, wir müssen bei
solchen Patienten die Anamnese
aus der Nase sehen.
Genau, das ist
vollkommen recht, ja, Sie haben
vollkommen recht, weil
so eine Patient versucht immer
die Probleme,
die das hat
oder hat er
nicht alles zu
beschreiben oder erklären.
Und da müssen Sie leider,
dann müssen Sie einfach immer alles
vertiefen, immer noch mal
wiederholen, noch mal nachfragen.
Wenn Sie einfach
übersichtlich
einfach durchgehen oder okay,
ich habe es jetzt gefragt, Alkohol, okay,
ist es nicht wichtig, dann
spring ich auf zweite Frage, ein dritter,
vierter, fünfter, dann
verlieren Sie denn den gesamten
Verlauf auch den, den
Hauptproblemen, woher kommt das denn.
Weil die haben am
meisten schon Probleme
dieserzeit, mehr als Monat
schon bekannt ist, es ein Jahr
noch bekannt sind.
Und die sagen nur, der letzte 3-4 Monat,
wenn man tief fragt, haben Sie letztes Jahr
auch so ein paar 12 Monate so leicht
einen Überbauchschmessen, ja,
ich habe es auch von zu gehabt, aber ich habe es
nicht wahrgenommen. Aber gibt es auch
umgekehrt Patient, die gar keine
Leib beschweren hat
und geht auf einmal mit
Überbauchschmessen oder Schluckmischweren
zum Haushalt.
Und die Haushaltsversuch, immer so
als psychologisches Problem
zu bezeichnen und sagt hier, nehmt Sie
eine Antidepressivung, Sie haben
Stress und gibt es die Patientin.
Ich habe ja zuletzt eine Patientin,
die 38 Jahre alt ist,
eine junge Frau, eine ganz junge
Lehrerin, kam
mit leider Magenkars-
in Bestattung 4, herpatsch,
Lymphatsch, Bretonial metastasiert
und die Diagnose
ist vor 3, problematisch
jetzt vor 2 Monaten
sicher gebt,
gab es sozusagen
und Bestattung hatte
gar keine Probleme, gar keine Leier.
Ich habe es immer wieder gefragt,
haben Sie gar kein Problem, gar keine,
ich habe alle Fragen geschrieben,
nein, habe ich gar kein Problem.
Die Lehrerin, die kann auch nicht
lügen, natürlich,
sozusagen von den
Kompetenzen aus, ein ganz gutem
Zustand. Und leider
kann es auch so, dass die Patientin
auch haben, dass in den letzten 2 Monaten
so schnell gewachsen ist.
Es ist nicht, dass jede Patientin
langfristige Probleme haben soll.
Daher, aber trotzdem
am meisten die haben,
selten haben sie gar kein Problem,
auf einmal treten das auf und dann
geht das so schnell los,
nur bei den Tumorarten,
die sehr aggressiv sind, geht das
am meisten so schnell los.
Bei
mittelgradiges
Tumorart, die wachsen
sehr langsam. Und da heißt
dann, hat man auch langfristige Probleme.
Genau so
beispielsweise bei Darmcrips,
sie haben 2 Jahre Probleme,
nach 2 Jahren kommt bei SIN, ja,
ich habe jetzt richtig verstoffen.
Das war immer mal wieder,
wieder, aber
so langsam wächst das,
bei Menschart und Tumor.
Daher
so, ich glaube,
wir haben ausfrültig gesprochen,
wenn sie keine mehr Fragen haben,
dann können wir dann
unserer anderen Lisa
abschließen.